[Musique]
redescendons sur terre maintenant avec
le salon de la restauration rapide
autrement dit le fast food quick mcdo
free time burger king cetera et cetera
se vendent comme des petits pains au
sens littéral du terme d'ailleurs 300
millions de repas en 1988 1630 points de
vente en france ce type de cuisine
industrielle nécessite des machines de
plus en plus performantes et sophistiqué
qui allie à la fois rapidité et hygiène
parfaite impressionnant vous allez le
voir en quête de valérie fournioux et
claude ban
discussions d'experts un pizzaïolo
phocéen compatriote médusés
comment cette pâte préparée par une
machine et huit ans seulement deux
minutes peut-elle être bonnes et
italiennes
[Musique]
parce que tout et veut lui s'est vite
que même les frites sont aujourd'hui
cuite 108 c'est bon
puisqu'il le dit dans l' empire du fast
food tout est mécanisé informatisé est
conditionnée
d'utilisation de la restauration
certainement et de la gastronomie
sûrement pas dans le prix la
restauration rapide 22 francs un repas
moyen le soir vous avez mangé dans un
restaurant 3 étoiles s'est dit
absolument rien à voir il ya aucun
danger braga premier procès le marché de
la restauration rapide a frôlé en 88 les
300 millions de repas chiffre d'affaires
6 milliards de francs le consommateur
classique a entre 18 et 34 ans adorent
le hamburger mange vite et paient en
espèces plus qu'une mode c'est devenu un
mode de vie d'une espèce de grand
micmacs culturel comme ça qu'ils se
produisent ce qui est vrai c'est que
notre alimentation change radicalement
depuis une vingtaine d'années
je ne pense pas qu'on aille vers
un processus complètement catastrophique
de standardisation de perte du goût etc
je crois qu'elle est deux qui progresse
de front aujourd'hui les grands trusts
de la restauration rapide change de look
ou leur menu et propose autre chose que
des hamburgers comme les salades
composées sans parler de diététique une
nette amélioration
si de façon exceptionnelle on rentre
dans un fast food pour y manger avec
plaisir ce qu'il faut surtout
déculpabiliser les gens vis-à-vis de cet
aspect péjoratif je répète à tous les
jours mais une fois de temps en temps
avec les enfants
c'est tout à fait acceptable
l'hygiène alimentaire s'apprend dès
l'âge du biberon une nourriture trop
riche en lipides et en sucre provoque
des maladies cardiovasculaires si
fréquentes en france
[Musique]